- See you got a prop on the table.
- This is one of our Cypress
Hill products. There you go.
- Yeah, yeah.
- That's fine, go ahead.
- Grinding it and crushing it.
- [Gary Vee] You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy,
don't you wanna be happy?
So back to how fun my life has
gotten in the last few years
as more eyes have been on me.
Waking up in the morning and
getting a DM from Cypress Hill
that's some shit.
I called every single
fucking person I went
to high school with and
just had the best time.
How did you get onto the,
like how did you even become
aware of the content, or what happened?
- Someone put me onto you.
- Like, yo go check this guy out?
- Yeah, and...
- And you got it right away?
- It started from there and we got it.
- The same way he got you
in the first 30 seconds
or a little bit longer?
- No, no, right off the top
because a lot of the stuff
that you're trying to instill
in people is inspirational.
In saying that there's no
obstacles, you can go do this
if you set your mind to task, boom.
Go get it.
No excuses and I love
that shit because that's
the way that we've always
approached making music.
We didn't let anything be an obstacle.
We believed in ourselves
and we set to task.
And here we are 27 years later
rocking out with Gary Vee.
- And what you were writing,
what you wrote made sense.
I finished the Crushing
It book in two days.
- I appreciate it.
- And it just made sense
especially being involved social
media wise and knowing how
to get your brand out there.
It just made sense.
- You know what's funny to me?
I always tell people, "It makes sense."
When people really didn't believe it,
the people that it most made sense to
were people that went through the machine
and made it, like you.
Cause then you knew how true
it was because you knew the
disadvantages of having
distribution have the leverage
instead of the creative.
- Right, and that's the business.
- There's serendipity into
you being here as well
it's just, that was the machine.
Thank God the right
people got eyes on you.
Thank God you had full
conviction and willing
to die on your sword.
But now the same you?
Let's pop that on SoundCloud and YouTube.
- Yeah.
- And you'll build all the leverage.
- That's the get down now.
- A hundred percent.
So what else is going on
in the entrepreneur land?
See you got a prop on the table.
- Yes, and this is actually for you.
- Let's talk about it.
Thank you my guy.
- This is one of our Cypress
Hill products in the cannabis--
- I love it.
Does it feel crazy to watch
cannabis go truly mainstream?
- It feels good.
- Obviously there's some federal stuff
that's gonna slow it
down a little bit, but--
- It feels good.
Because I mean, it validates all the...
There you go, yeah, that's fine.
- That's fine.
- Crushing it.
(laughs)
- Grinding it and crushing it.
- Go ahead.
- No, it feels great because,
I mean all the sacrifices
that we made in talking
about it in the music
because when we started it was taboo.
- Taboo as fuck.
- Especially in hip hop.
- Are you kidding, Nancy
Reagan just had her run.
Seriously, like literally
I'm telling you right now.
We've talked about it,
it's like I don't smoke
or do any of that literally
because of Nancy Reagan.
My mom completely and utterly
bought into that propaganda
and then pushed that
shit on me, a hundred.
- Yeah, so we had opportunities,
you know, leave the table
because of our politics
and our stance on cannabis
and stuff like that.
So to see it now come to fruition,
everything that we've thought could happen
and we believed could happen.
- And wait the next 20, 30 years.
- And here we are.
And I know Jack Herer's
dancing around wherever he's at
in Heaven if you believe in that.
He's probably dancing around,
celebrating, smoking one
with some archangels and
whatnot because he's the one
that put us down with a
lot of the information
that would be for us--
- Foundational.
- Yeah, that we would
give out to our fans.
A lot of other artists followed suit.
Now, you had reggae artists
like Bob Marley and Peter Tosh
and all those guys, those legends
that were championing the
cause, but I don't think reggae
hit mainstream the way hip hop did
and I think that was our power
is that we had mainstream
success with our brand
of hip hop that actually
had the legalization politics in it.
Which blew it up and it caused
other artists in hip hop
to follow us and other
artists outside of hip hop.
- Listen, everybody watching,
take it from an old soul
who loves to figure out what
the seed is that creates stuff,
these guys created the
framework of what the mid 90
and late 90 and early 2000
guys and gals talked about.
They gave permission to
the Snoops of the world
period, truth, end of story.
It's just the truth!
- Thank you.
- Just facts.
You know why?
You extended the rubber band.
Tyler's not in here.
Tyler, my admin, one of the
things I was telling him,
he does so much more work in 10 hours
than he ever thought he could.
- [Breal] Right.
- And when you love what
you do and when you see it,
and you do it, you can
stretch the rubber band
and it gives you permission
to fill that bag.
- Mm-hmm, right.
- That's what you guys did
for cannabis, marijuana, weed.
You stretched it, made
it a little less taboo.
Don't forget, you guys know this.
This is just history lessons.
Len Bias.
- Len Bias, yeah.
- When Len Bias dies,
America went tight on drugs.
- [Breal] Yeah, exactly, oh yeah.
- For all the kids watching,
imagine if Kevin Durant
gets drafted and three days
later dies from cocaine
and there's no internet
and everybody in the world
is just paying attention to one story.
That's what happened
and he went to Maryland,
right in Washington D.C.
Nancy jumped on that, scared
the fuck out of everybody.
- Everybody, yeah.
- I thought if I smoked a
cigarette I would die on the spot.
- Yeah, I mean--
- Between that and Magic, in 91 with AIDS?
I was finished, I couldn't do anything.
I was like church boy, I
was scared of everything.
Sex, drug, I was like, "No, no no."
Everything was scary, everyone's dying.
I don't want to die.
That stuff sounds real good
and fucking, I kind of want it
but fuck it, I don't wanna die.
That's what 1988-91 was.
- Yeah, the propaganda
machine was rolling hard.
- So anything against
that was like, real taboo.
- Yeah, it was hardcore,
it was definitely hardcore.
But, you still have to push
through that to have people
see the benefits and I think
that's what we were able to do.
- What can the Vanyer community,
me, what are the things
that we can help you with?
I feel like you've given
so much to my entertainment
and escapism and brought so much value.
Anything we can help with?
Anything that's important?
- No, enjoy the music man, I
mean that's our first passion
that we started with was the music.
We just put out Elephants on Acid.
It's a new body of work
that's very trippy, dark,
psychedelic and we want
people to see this new brand,
well this new form of an
old formula, if you will.
Like a upgraded version and
I think they're gonna go
on a ride with that.
Aside from that, we have our
doc that we're working out.
- And you're doing a GoFundMe right?
Indiegogo.
- Indiegogo campaign on that.
- Let's link up the new album
and the campaign on this video
on Facebook, YouTube, all that stuff.
Let's do a swipe up.
Swipe up if you wanna get on the doc.
- Swipe it.
- There you go.
- And what's that about, how
much are you guys raising
on that campaign?
- I don't know exactly what the--
- [Man] It's looking at
around a hundred thousand.
- Yeah, and it's basically to
tell our story from A to B.
- You're gonna pop that on
YouTube and Facebook and that?
- Yeah, every platform.
- [Gary] Just put it out,
on the website and all that?
- Yeah for us it's just about
telling our story A to Z.
A lot of the times the in between shit
that helped us form what we have today,
that never gets talked
about and like our history.
- Actual structure.
- Yeah, so we wanna give that to our fans.
- That's what I'm saying.
And what about touring?
What's going on these days?
- Yeah, we just got
back from South America
and Mexico and Canada.
This whole month we've been out.
We're gonna keep going at it.
We've got December, all
of December in Europe.
And then next February,
March, the United States.
It's well known Cypress
Hill, we tour, we tour hard.
- [Breal] Yeah, we stay on the road.
- We're a touring band.
I think we tour harder than
any hip hop artist out there.
- Yeah we're gonna be out
there with Hollywood Undead
in February and March
for that particular run.
After that, we're just sort
of looking for the new dates
into the summer and the rest.
So, it's a lot of road
work for us because still,
we still carry that same mentality.
Gotta play in front of
people, gotta win them over,
gotta do it.
- And then once you do years
and years consecutively,
you're doing that over and over again,
it kinda gets in your DNA
and you have to get out
and you have to go perform,
you gotta hear the crowd cheer.
- I can't believe you just said that,
I literally the other day said, "Oh fuck."
I travel so much now,
that when I don't I kinda
am going through a detox.
- [Breal] It feels weird.
- I don't feel right.
- It feels weird.
- Yeah, two much time at
home is crazy at first.
For us, we do so much road work.
- How many days at home are you?
- It depends
- [Breal] That's hard to say.
- Well, what's your gut tell you?
- We all have Cypress Hill and
everybody has a side project
too, like I play in PowerFlo,
he plays in Prophets
and he does his thing with
Rhettmatic with Cypress Junkie.
So at any given time we could be--
- You're just juggling.
- It could be like maybe six
to seven months of road work
and then the rest, it
just sort of sporadically.
- Anything I can answer for
you guys before we bounce here?
More like selfish, not for
content, like anything I can?
- Aw man, no, we're just
glad to be with you here man
and we appreciated taking
the time to have us up here.
- I got one question.
Do you remember where you were at
when you first heard Cypress Hill?
- Yeah, I do actually.
What is it?
I was in, it's either one of two parties
in the summer I think in
between 89 and 90, right?
I'm trying to think who was.
It was at Denise Malaney's
8th grade pool party.
(laughs)
- [Breal] That's a good start.
- And in Bethlehem Township, New Jersey
which is like the sticks.
- Yeah, sounds like it.
- It sounds like it.
And you guys know this, you
guys had such a different sound.
And that catches people's attention.
And, yeah I do.
And then Robby Turnick, Jesus
Christ, one of my best friends
I mean, he would fuckin'...
We would play Nintendo baseball,
like just regular Nintendo baseball
when Genesis was already out.
But we'd still go back to the
old school and he would just
play that shit on repeat.
- Did you have to hide
the CD from your parents?
- No, my parents, my Russian
mother didn't give a fuck.
She wasn't in my business.
Like, you know what I mean?
My mom was like--
- She let you be a boy, a young man.
- Yeah she was like go out...
She was like, don't come back
until 8PM and eat dinner.
She was not in my shit.
- Now, that's cool.
- Yeah, real cool.
First of all, she fuckin'
put a macro spell on me
and she knew I was good boy.
Second of all, I fuckin' worked all...
Dude, I didn't give a fuck
about anything but money.
- That's right.
- I was fucking working.
It snowed?
My mom wasn't worried that I
was in a basement with a bunch
of kids drinking cause
it was snowing outside.
- Cause if you're working too much.
- She knew I was struggling.
She knew exactly where I was.
"Ding, dong.
"Would you give me 20 bucks
shovel your driveway?"
I fuck with fucking working artists.
- Gotta do it, yeah.
- It's one thing that you
culturally were at that time
when it mattered to me.
It matters way more to
me, on the shit we DM
about the entrepreneurial spirit,
the fact that you guys are iconic
and touring seven fuckin months.
You're my kind of people.
- Man, likewise.
- Thank you.
- Real pleasure.
- I got one last question and
I read something about this
in your book.
Do you still think Alexa is the way to go
because of that whole--
- I think everybody's gonna be like,
"Alexa, play Cypress Hill."
This is gonna be a lot of music.
- [Alexa] Turning on songs by Cypress Hill
on Amazon Music.
- This right there, what
I just did, is a lot
of what's gonna happen.
Alexa, louder.
- Cause I was going to
get it and then that whole
controversy happened.
- Listen.
- I was gonna get it because you said.
- You know what, you more than anybody?
Even if they're watching
live your fuckin' life.
- [Breal] True that.
- There it is.
- Right, right?
I literally, for the last
eight years, cause I knew
this was all gonna happen to me,
have been living my life on the record.
Every meeting, every interaction.
I just knew in my heart, I knew
this was gonna happen for me
and I was like, fuck it.
I'm not gonna give one
person that actually knows me
anything other than I'm
the best fuckin' dude.
I'm just gonna live my life.
(rock music)